wow
[Applause]
did she
these rings
signify
sorry
i thought it was on silent
these rings
so help me thomas
[Music]
okay sorry sorry excuse me this is an
this better be emergency i just
are you skiing snowboarding actually but
i need your help now life or death
situation this very second i need you to
use the ring i gave you to save me like
right now okay slow down slow down i
don't even know where you are you just
got a picture where you want the ring to
go so picture this
okay okay hang on
[Music]
what
did you throw it
oh god what what tell me what what oh
god i think i mixed up the rings when i
was teasing jojo what where is it then
where is it
[Music]
you don't want to know oh but i do tom i
very much want to know before i become a
hedgehog flavored snow cone hang tight
buddy
i got this with this one
rachel
hi hey
hi
uh everything okay bud
not really what are you doing this is
gonna sound really crazy but i'm gonna
need to see that ring for just one
second one second have you lost your
mind i'm gonna give it right back i
promise you guys please randall it's
really important can i no bro go sit
down randall give me the ring please
just okay randall don't look at him look
at me run around one second put the ring
on my finger you know right now listen
to me randall look at me ring on my face
give me the ring give me just one second
put a ring on it
please love okay
with this ring yes i'm so sorry about
this
[Applause]
[Music]
snowmaker oh boy
[Music]